je sais pas encore ce que je suis je
veux vivre ma vie au jour le jour
tu devrais dans la rue a été les gens je
te signale que j'ai rien demandé
j'ai été placé dans une espèce
d'aquarium comme un poisson exotique
j'en suis ressortie avec des capacités
et qu'on me fiche la paix ce serait un
sacré gâchis
à l'aim l'éternel symbole de l'espoir
mais aussi de la prospérité
il ya trop de choses dans leur laine qui
se passe dans l'ombre les gens craignent
ce qu'ils ne peuvent pas voir
ce club c'est ma réputation
ces morceaux en héritage vous allez
faire la tournée il est pressés comme
des citrons
parce que tout le monde a envie d'être
le roi
parfois quand on veut faire respecter la
justice
rien de tel que de faire soi même
tu vas nous donner cet argent
j'aime pas le temps que tu prends
et vous avez ma parole madame je vous
protégera nos mains
c'est
déclarer la guerre je vais t'en donner
de la guerre tu es peut-être à l'épreuve
des balles mais harlem ne l'est pas
allen est censé représenter tous nos
espoirs et nos rêves
se battre pour la justice et chaque jour
qui passe
vous pouvez au moins nous dire comment
vous habiller tout le quartier n'arrête
pas de parler de sites et de 2 sega qui
se sont fait dérouiller dans un resto
hier soir moi on m'a dit qu'ils étaient
quatre
sur ma charge
voilà
non seulement aux asperges
ap
moi
le ballet week-end sometimes i feel good
je sais ce qui va petit galet youth of
sciences
des os comprenez
trois questions
demain
ce baromètre
à
mais si je pense tu vois plus m
r2 faille pour un puissant gaudillière
faudrait mieux